[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and
host of the entree leadership podcast
and the fine print podcast joined today
by my best friend dr john deloney host
of the dr john deloney show and we are
here for you america to take your
questions about life money mental health
boundaries crypto you name it there's a
wide spectrum out there john and we are
here to help those that are in a
crossroads if you need some confirmation
if you've got a burning question we're
here for you and christy kicks us off
this hour in charlotte north carolina
christy welcome to the show
thank you how are you we're doing great
how can we help
um okay i'm going to try to get through
this um
it's emotional my husband's 39 year old
sister died in a car accident in june of
this year
[Applause]
and she left behind two daughters 17 and
21 years old who now live with my
husband's parents
um
the 21 year old graduated from college
in may after she
in three years and is starting a job as
a high school math teacher this month
and the 17 year old doesn't have a
driver's license yet but she wants to
get a job after that and i'm just trying
to
i want to
i'd like to maybe purchase them
financial peace university my husband
and i joined in january and we've paid
off 26 thousand dollars in debt so far
wow um at the same time as paying our
daughters college tuition
so i feel like it would help
them start out their lives but also they
just lost their mom i don't know how to
broach the subject if i just shouldn't
because it's none of my business
or
anyway so oh gosh i'm so sorry um
this is one of those devastating moments
if you were in the booth here with me
and george you can feel it in here like
uh
that's that's the is the worst thing you
can imagine right yeah um
so for we'll give you fpu for both the
girls like we'll take that off the table
don't worry about that um
a quick question here
is dad still in the picture
um
he pays child support but he is
remarried and lives in a different town
with his wife and their newborn and her
three children okay
um do you have a relationship with these
girls
uh yes they are like my other children
okay have you been with them over the
last 30 days or the last month and a
half
yeah we spend all the time in the world
with them yeah okay
um
so the challenge here is you're grieving
deeply
yes and that's why i don't know if it's
a good time to bring it up because it's
like
that's probably the last thing on their
mind but with her starting a new job
it's also the perfect time to get her a
head start in life right so
you're going to have a delicate balance
of both hand
what you cannot do
is use doing things for these girls make
them
responsible for your healing through
this grief okay
and
you've stepped into a role because this
is the character of person you are the
relationship relationship you had with
them of some sort of maternal proxy for
them they need a mother figure as
they're trying to navigate what's going
to be a
wild
decade for them right one and heading
into their 20s and the other heading
into life after high school and so
they'll need you to step into that role
if they invite you in
and at the same time you're gonna have
to make sure your
service to them isn't um
isn't the way you're gonna find healing
through this thing okay
okay so you're gonna have to be really
open and honest with yourself about i
need to go talk to somebody i need to
grieve this i need to have a core group
of women my age who are doing my that i
can talk to
and
sitting down with these young ladies and
saying hey i'm willing to step in in any
way shape form or fashion as we head off
into life without your mom
and the greatest gift you can give them
is to let them see you grieve because if
they don't they're gonna think they're
crazy for being as as
heartbroken and distraught as they are
okay seeing an adult that they trust and
love in their life be super sad gives
them permission to be sad which is the
path towards healing okay
and then yes sitting down and saying hey
we are um anything you'll need here's
here's some money here's the book here's
the thing
ask if they are interested in those type
of things and be ready to present them
if they are okay
but right this second
i mean you can talk to them they're
going to be in shock for a season
right
right oh yeah i mean it was
it was actually on the 17 year old
daughter's birthday
what a mess so
yeah i mean it's
yeah
yeah
there's
you're grasping to make sense of what's
next and there's just going to be a
season of darkness
and there's going to be a season of
somebody we got to pay the bills right
so making sure the four walls are
covered that we talk about here
um yes that and like i said they're
living with my in-laws so the four walls
are covered
the greatest gift you can give them
right now i said i'll add a second thing
the first one is a limp see agree the
second one is just presence
just presence just showing up and not
trying to solve anything for them right
now but just showing up and being a
an adult who loves them in their
presence and being sad with them and
those weird little moments of laughter
that you can't stop but you don't
understand why because you're supposed
to be sad right all of that emotion uh
being present with them and they're not
gonna remember what y'all talked about
they won't remember the deep dark talks
and they'll remember that um
you know that aunt christy kept showing
up and then kristy kept showing up and
christy kept showing up
does that help
yeah can i just tell you me and george
i'm so sorry
thank you i'm so sorry for your brother
i'm sorry for you i'm sorry for your
whole family i'm sorry for those two
young women
you're an incredible gift to them
christy uh even without
monetary gifts uh just carrying this
deeply for those girls uh
is probably gonna do more than any
financial gift you can give to them and
it sounds like they've got a good head
on their shoulders they're gonna be all
right but the more you show up for them
and the more uh you help them you know
there's a lot of life to be lived
they're 17 and 21 and so this is not a
what to do in the next six months this
is what does the next 10 years look like
of supporting them and being this
maternal proxy like john mentioned but
we want to be a part of that by gifting
them financial peace university i hope
they go through it i don't know that i
would have at 17 in this in this stage
of life and what they're going through
but it's there when they want it yeah
and and uh we'll throw in the app too
that may be the you could be like hey
we're good financial peace and we've got
this app and they'll be like all right
i'll look at the app but we'll send you
the every dollar app too we'll send you
three of those one for each one of them
and one for you and your husband to use
um and you can
say hey we'll we'll step in the gap here
if they roll their eyes and and they're
like now it's not the time and christy
we could care less but that's fine they
are young people grieving because their
entire world has um been dumped upside
down and there's they're going to grieve
this for a long long time as george said
we're settling in for the long game on
this one i'm so so sorry i'm going to go
ahead and send you a copy of dr john's
book own your past change your future
and ken coleman's book from paycheck to
purpose
to maybe helped out that 17 year old as
she figures out what the new normal
looks like as she figures out education
and adulthood and all this stuff so
thank you so much for the call christy
so sorry for what you're going through
with those girls are going through we're
cheering you guys on for what's next and
hang on the line austin will pick up
we'll get you on your pass change your
future from paycheck to purpose
financial peace university two sets of
that and every dollar premium for the
girls thanks so much for the call and
trusting us with the situation more of
your calls coming up triple eight eight
two five five two two five this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by dr
john deloney this is the ramsey show
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're taking your
questions about life money mental health
relationships you name it rachel joins
us up next in chicago rachel welcome to
the show
hi thank you for having me on the show
hey how are you doing what's going on
good
i was just calling with a quick question
here um it's actually pretty similar to
the last caller but
at what point do we stop helping family
financially
my brother was
murdered a couple years ago and he left
behind a three-year-old
so
our niece
and we've helped you know mom out
as she was a single mom for a year or so
and now she's moved on
married
and
you know we offered to adopt our niece
and for turned down and we don't really
see a future for them
to be self-sustaining in her new
relationship and her outlook in life and
just um you know overall so i just don't
really know what to do at this point our
niece is three years old
and i would like your thoughts on you
know where to go from here how to help
but not enable
um and how to really help her when she's
you know a stayed away so do you not
trust her with the money that you're
sending at this point is that the real
issue yes you want to support your niece
but you don't think it's actually going
to support your niece
in the right way is your is your niece
niece safe
um
well that's questionable we do i mean
that's
yes or no is that kid being abused
sexually um psychologically is a kid
getting food is kids safe this could get
neglected
their um
bcfs has been involved in the past okay
and um you know for neglect and things
like that so
i would say at this point we don't have
any knowledge of that
happening but it i i think it's a high
possibility in the future
okay
if um i i i don't that's one of the few
things i just simply don't mess around
with even a little bit if i have an
inkling knit because it's a child
mistake right and i'd
i'd rather
sleep at night knowing that somebody
doesn't like me and their child's safe
than the other way around okay
um so if you ever get an inkling that
the child's not safe then we're gonna
make that call again we're gonna make it
again we're gonna make it again i know
that system is a jacked up mess but
we're gonna keep making that call
um
yes so we do keep in contact and make
sure that we're always calling and
checking up on her and just but hold on
here's the other side of it
it is really hard to hear
that little girl is her child
right
and
the more you
are grieving through trying to insert
yourself into this little child's life
the bigger of a mess this is going to
turn into
see what i'm saying
this has become a proxy for your grief
and so like george asked a great
question like are you not trusting with
the money then stop sending the money
like yeah we're not
yeah then stop sending it i would have a
meeting i would have a conversation say
hey here's it's been a year and a half
you've moved on you're you're remarried
or whatever you are
um
we're going to stop doing x we may
create an account for her college
because that's what we're going to do
over time um that only she will have
access to uh but
we're gonna
we're gonna begin to let you fly on your
own right i'm gonna have that
conversation i'm just gonna cut off one
weekend right um but but
channel your grief and channel your
frustration and channel some of your
hurt into something that's going to be
more fruitful
okay but right now you're trying to
parent by proxy and it's just causing a
mess for you it's causing a mess for
them it's just becoming a convoluted you
see what i'm saying
yes and it's hard i know what i'm
telling you is hard it's hard
the the the hard part about this is that
it almost feels like
you know then we won't have any access
to her at all and so here's the hard
part that's her kid and if she wants to
deny access to her aunts and uncles
unfortunately she's allowed to do that
okay what i would want is a track record
uh like there's no there's no legal
right i would say there might even be a
moral ethical right but there's no legal
right that an uncle have to access to
somebody else's child
i would want to uh to create a track
record
where that kid will know that aunt
so-and-so and uncle so and so wrote me a
card every week
every week they i got something in the
mail from them for my whole childhood
and that three-year-old that
seven-year-old that nine-year-old that
14 year old won't get it that 22 year
old will
that 29 year old will
she'll go through life knowing i know
somebody who loves me see what i'm
saying we're playing a long game here
now
okay
so rachel you said you've stopped
sending money to them but you're still
wondering how can we help without
monetarily gifting money
yes i mean we this came kind of all to a
hedge because she's asking for money now
and this is now the next iteration of
now we need money for this and now we
need some money for that and we haven't
sent it because i wanted to talk to you
first
yeah so i sit down and say if it's about
clothes or if it's about food i might
like i'll do it if you're asking me for
help financially and my my help comes
with fill in the blank it's your money
i'll help you do a budget that's the
only way i'm going to give you money
i will help you with x y and z that's
only i'm going to give you money i'm
going to do it one more time and you
need to know this is the last from where
this comes from we're creating a college
account for her but see what i'm saying
like it's your money so it's your
boundaries and it's your decisions and
you can put all kind of hoops you want
to and if she says i'm not doing all
that that's great you're choosing not to
take my money that's her choice not
yours see what i'm saying
yeah
and i know again all that's hard what's
the hesitation
that she's not gonna want to do it cool
she's not gonna do it yeah she's she's
opting out
and i say cool not in a that's not great
for that kid i'm sure i'm not saying
like all right it's not like that you
know what i mean like she's making grown
up choices
right
sounds like the next step is another
hard conversation to go listen i want to
support this little girl who i care
deeply about but it's going to be on my
terms
and the the conversation before that one
is with your with your husband and
you'll sit down and say here's what
we're willing to do and here's how far
we're willing to go
and this is what our boundaries are
going to be and then just know that
anytime you set boundaries everyone
around you and your life are going to
try to test those boundaries to see if
they hold
she's going to call you desperate at
midnight i gotta have food food money or
the kids hungry they're gonna come test
those boundaries and you're gonna have
to decide up front how firm we're gonna
hold right
and then from there you gotta make peace
with that's her child and if you get
wind over not being safe i'm gonna make
those calls but i'm not gonna try to
armchair parent somebody else's kid in a
different house from far away
right
okay i think that's really good advice i
think i think i can see myself doing
that in
a variety of
instances of parenting and it's a little
hard because we did parent her she you
know she was placed in our home as a
foster child when she was born wow hey
rachel like
i think it's wise for you and your
husband to go grieve this like a loss
you love this little girl don't you
yeah and you loved her dad didn't you
yes yeah
you'll need to grieve the loss and the
three-year-old can't prop up you in your
husband's grief okay
there's a hole there and y'all gotta
address the whole y'all gotta sit in the
hole for a while
and um
find some more productive avenues to
give you peace you'll make meaning on
the back end of this right we're going
to take care of kids that's going to be
that's going to be who we are we take
care of kids whose parents pass away or
we take care of kids who are struggling
we're going to be foster parents
that's we're going to make meaning on
the back end of this but right now we
have to grieve it and i don't know that
y'all are there yet
is that fair
yes okay
hey we'll walk with you we love you um
i'm gonna send you two copies of
financial peace university okay it's me
and george it's our gift to you um
you can sit down and say hey i'm going
to offer this to you and i'll go with it
go with go through this with you
and that's going to be the condition of
me giving you any more money and this is
the last time we do like whatever i'm
not going to give you parameters what
they happen to be but i'm going to give
you some cash to get some food and
diapers right now but i'm also going to
give you a tool that's going to help you
change this thing and you're right she's
probably not going to do it she's
probably not
but you'll be able to sleep at night
knowing i put a fishing pole and weights
and bait and hooks and know how on the
front porch she chose to not go fishing
yeah and ask her what exactly she needs
and then you can go drop the diapers at
the door if you don't trust her what
she's doing with the money then you
provide exactly what the thing is and
you can sleep easy at night knowing you
did what was right for you but hang on
the line austin will pick up we'll get
you two copies of financial peace
university to help walk through this
with them and hopefully
create some semblance of a relationship
so that you can have relationship with
that little girl thanks so much for the
call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
every time you hear someone do their
debt free scream on this show it's
because at some point they said enough
i'm not living like this anymore i've
had it and when you get mad like that
and do what they did your life will
change too and right now inflation and
your stupid credit cards are killing you
you've started to believe you're not in
control of your money that it's all just
happening to you but you're wrong and
you've got to decide to control what you
can control and that's you that person
in the mirror your behavior you have the
power to change your future and
financial peace university will show you
how this course will teach you the
proven step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly 10 million people beat debt
master budgeting and build wealth and
you can do it too and i get it when i
first started this thing i went george's
plan is fantastic but it also
ended up with him being broke so let's
try this other plan over here and guys
that almost a decade ago that changed my
life
so stop letting debt and money stress
control your life say enough and take
back your control start financial peace
university at ramseysolutions.com
enough that's ramsay solutions.com
enough the way you started that ad
um when you said
every time
it made me think of that song
every time somebody says the words every
time i think that's what triggers me
and that was a glimpse into the dark
mind of dr john everything i think about
you my good friend i think of bling
bling you always look nice you always
look wow thank you thank you wow you've
come a long way since two days ago john
made fun of my denim jacket for no
reason no it's corduroy and it's august
that's saying that sounds about right
let's go to the phones where i'm safe
michelle joins us there to save us all
michelle welcome to the ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
absolutely
yeah so um i have a question my house is
going up for sale now
and
i also have
a lot of investment savings
and
i'm in a very strange situation where
i'm currently looking for a job so i
don't have
that income and my family is helping me
out until i do
did you quit your job or get fired what
happened
no i have not had a career i'm 56
i used to
work in
as a volunteer in with foster kids for
about eight years so i'm hoping to
leverage that and i've been
for almost two years studying
to do something around that
so that's what i've been looking for
right now
if i don't get that i'll get something
else okay are you married
no no okay so up to this point where has
your income come from
well
i've been saving over the years um i was
supported from uh by my family at that
time
and slowly built up
right now at 705 thousand in the index
fund that's incredible ways they would
support you and you would take that
money and put it in savings zoda means
yes
so you live off some of it and invest
the rest was that the idea
correct and then i i don't have any debt
i have um the house is going on the
market for i'll probably get 5 20 when
it's done
um and that's step free
as well
so the home is paid for so you're
getting all the net proceeds after fees
yeah which you think will be 520. wait
i'm still confused you don't work
well don't work
i worked for free basically for years
as a volunteer right i'm trying to
i will have to work let me put it that
way i need to get a job for sure so
i'm doing that
because the family supports jobs
yesterday for example okay you know
that's what i'm doing but you're a
millionaire who's never held a paying
job right correct wow
was this a trust fund of sorts where
you know for 56 years or what was the
story there i'm just curious
we don't talk to a lot of millionaires
who've never worked this is a new for
us well
you tell us as much as you want to yeah
right and preferably all of it because
i'd love to know
well
that's really all i can say okay um i i
have but i will
here's what's happened
i was into the understanding that that
would be
forever
and was told
that when i suggested that you know hey
i need to go and get this
career going why don't you just go back
to volunteering
with the foster kid you know
children's medical and all that so
i didn't and that was my mistake and now
i'm scrambling trying to put a career
together which is great but hold on we
don't we don't need to scramble michelle
you've got a million dollars plus
in your net worth
mm-hmm to cram
you've got a big pile of money to float
you d until you can find a job that you
actually enjoy yeah
like
well i want to put it all in the index
fund
or most of it from from my house and i'm
wondering if that's just not
what to do
well where are you going to live once
you sell this house
well i was going to rent for six to 12
months and then i obviously have to
downsize
to conserve you know
and it's just you
yes okay
so i like the idea of renting you're
gonna need a pile of money to do that
we're gonna need a fully funded
emergency fund which we don't really
know what your bills are quite yet so i
probably just to be safe maybe put away
50 to 100 000
and you can invest the rest if you're
not sure what you're going to do with it
for now uh which i have 80 cash right
now okay so you re you're in a good spot
there so this 520 added to the 705 that
puts a million two in that account right
yes and so if that account grows at
let's say nine or ten percent you could
peel off you know seventy thousand
dollars a year and probably not touch
the principal for a long time
so you can create an income off of that
i guess i'm worried that that first
something happens the first year
and it clobbers 30 percent i think
michelle you have a million
dollars
even if it covers thirty percent no
you're 56 you've invested for the long
term so we're not hungry what happens in
the next six to 12 months this is a long
term play
and you don't lose money unless you cash
it out right which i have plenty of time
left to work at least a decade so and
you're asking me and george we can't
tell you that the the market could lose
30 percent over the
one calendar year the chances of that
happening are so comically minuscule
that it's not worth spit we could get
hit by a meteorite too both of those
things could happen if you've got 80 000
and 1.2 million dollars in investments
you're doing better than
99.999 percent of the money of any human
who's ever lived on the on the facebook
okay so yeah just know that you're doing
30 years of living left and
i don't want to touch that nest egg ever
so i'll be working my butt off of course
but um i just thank you that i feel
better well it sounds like
right now this is just such a new
strange phase for you where you're going
okay for 56 years i haven't had to do
this thing and all of a sudden you feel
like it's a scramble but you've got time
you've got money and those are the two
greatest resources anyone could have can
i tell you the one thing i'm way more
worried about your money i'm way more
worried about you
having purpose
a reason for getting up every day
a reason a thing you are contributing to
to make the world a better place which
then like i'm gonna do hard stuff during
the day
and that's
that's gonna bring my body peace it's
gonna be that's what joy is right
and you're gonna get frustrated and
annoyed and kids are gonna throw up on
you like i'm gonna go through hard stuff
every day
and that's gonna it's gonna it's gonna
connect with me at a soul level i'm
worried about you not having any purpose
yeah so that that's where the job comes
in that i'm currently competing with no
you can't let a job be your purpose
a job is part of the mission of who you
like it's a manifestation of who you are
like my purpose is to help people if my
job is helping people on youtube i'm
going to go sideways quick you see what
i'm saying
but if i get fired today and i work at
burger king tomorrow i shout out way to
go burger king there's your uh there's
your ad for the day i i
am going to help people in that job
right that's just that's gonna be who i
am so i want you to find a purpose
and a job right michelle i might take
that home profit and put her down a
money market savings account for now
high yield savings account and maybe you
purchase a place for yourself a condo
with cash so you can remove that fixed
expense on top of that i'm gonna gift
you our friend ken coleman's get clear
assessment to help you figure out what's
next and his book from paycheck to
purpose which will guide you to exactly
what john is talking about
what a strange situation john but a good
place to be i'll take it worst problems
to have out there thanks for the call
michelle appreciate it this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney you know john i did an instagram
q a yesterday you know we ten we do that
on occasion to get some questions and
i'm doling out life-changing financial
advice left and right it's the same
advice i get just as your friend exactly
for free it's all for free john and uh
someone asked hey let's see the i
mentioned that i have apps on my phone
in folders
on the second page alphabetical folders
categorized
and that was the one that got all the
response no one cared about the life
changing financial advice they were all
very impressed with my categorized
folders so that's my life hack for you
my life hack is yes they fit on one page
they fit right on the on the front i
have 266 apps yes wow yeah i'm a digital
hoarder i could see that yeah
anyways
you've got that's great is it i'm great
i feel like i need to see someone about
that nope i don't know why i'm all of my
friends have different things that they
do in their life it's great different
values the more you say that's great the
less i believe you
well open phones this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
take your questions about life money and
apps if you're curious you know all the
apps that you have off top of your head
no absolutely not i downloaded them nine
years ago and i said i was wondering
yeah a buddy of mine was like why do you
have seven sleep apps like i don't know
i don't use any of them gotcha i don't
sleep there you go there we go danielle
joins us up next in st louis danielle
welcome to the show
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call absolutely what's going on
well i am just starting out um i started
june 3rd and
went right into baby step 2.
i guess i have a two-part question
first i am
struggling with figuring out the budget
aspect of it i know they you guys say it
takes about three months and i'm
starting to see it working out a little
better um but i
just am having trouble with figuring out
um how to have patience
and not pay all my bills right up front
on that first paycheck and then waiting
and not having any money when i get to
my second paycheck oh so you're draining
the checking account
right away overzealous
okay my bills
so that's part of it and then i also
just feel like i need
a goal um of when i should be having
like how much i should be paying towards
it so i can be out of debt by a certain
point hang towards the debt
yes oh and i should be out of baby step
two do you have margin right now my
numbers
um so i
uh take home about 2500 a month for my
primary job
and i
just this week started a part-time for
nights and weekends job where i'll
probably be taking home about 600 800
extra a month right
and i am doing doordash on
occasion as well so probably about 100
to 300 a month from that
as far as what i have in debt
and i have um just under 42 000 to go
so
that is
4 800 i'm sorry 4 200 is credit cards um
32 000
is student loans
and um i also have a car fleece for
about 5 500 still to go okay
cool about halfway through that so let's
get to your budgeting question
you can change a lot of the dates the
bills are due on and so if you're
experiencing that you can go in online
or call them and say hey i want this
bill to come out on the 16th
and i want this bill to come out on the
18th and that way you can control some
of these variables in your budget do you
have any buffer in your checking account
um well that's what i'm also trying to
figure out is how to
put that in my
in my budget so that i have leftover
money at the end of the month
because i know you said you probably
need about 100 to 300
as a cushion so i'm trying to figure out
how to play that so i can just save that
in my checking account first and
foremost so you said your take home pays
2500 what are your expenses if you're
doing this budget
have you added that up
if you add in all your minimum payments
on your debts
minimum payments on my debt
is about
550
and i've been trying to pay about um 850
to 900 a month okay so you have about
three 400 bucks of margin right now to
throw with the debt
yes and you're going to start these side
hustles which will bring in another
thousand and so that's going to really
speed up this process i mean that'll you
make it happen three times as fast
that's what i'm hoping
i love it so are you using every dollar
right now or you have a different
budgeting method that's working for you
i'm i'm just i started financial peace
and i'm using um the premium every
dollar oh awesome okay well i was gonna
gift it to you so you beat me to the
punch thank you
and so your second question was what
um
so i just want to have a goal i know it
has it in the in the app but i just feel
like
it's telling me 2027 and i just feel
like that is
unreasonable what is your yearly income
um
well i just have my primary i don't know
about the others but my primary is about
four just under 49 000. okay what do you
do
i am an accounts receivable so i post a
lot of payments
why do you do accounts receivable
well why
well
i don't know do you love it i
i don't hate it
i i am a money person
if i said do you love your spouse you're
like i don't hate them honey do you love
me i don't hate you john i don't hate
you actually i have gotten that response
before
um here's what i'm saying
money goes one of two ways you get more
on the front end or you stop spending
less on the back end right and so
you're a money person you know how money
works i'd love to see you double your
income whether you go be an assistant
cfo or go
yeah but your whole call you're asking
like i don't like you're a money person
you're an accounts receivable you have a
degree in this stuff
and you're asking i don't oh you don't
okay so you've got experience let me say
that you've got experience in it
um
you're not suffering from knowledge
issues you're suffering from confidence
issues where does this come from
um
i'm i i'm not sure part of it is i feel
like i'm not in the right career path
yeah
my 32 000 in student loan debt is for a
degree i'm not really using what's your
degree part of that
my degree was in media communications
with public relations as um my track
okay can i tell you the accountants that
i've worked with and there's been a
bajillion of them
that can talk to me and explain what
they're actually doing
it's invaluable
and they make their way up the ranks the
the two cfos here at ramsey are two of
the coolest funniest hilarious guys and
they know how excel works which makes
them like unicorns right
and so you have a degree in media
community you have a degree in
communicating with other people and you
know how numbers work see what i'm
getting at you didn't waste your degree
in fact you've got a set of skills now
that people in your field are short on
that makes you very valuable so i'm
saying i'm trying to find ways to give
you confidence here
and not this i don't even know how to
like what's the math problem you do math
for a living you know right
i don't know what's holding you back
yeah i don't know i guess i just don't
know
i i love the place where i work and so i
guess i have some hesitance in finding
new employment
and you can love another place too
you know you don't love going home every
night not able to sleep because you owe
so much money
yes and you don't love getting off an
accounting job that you've been working
on five days a week to only work
weekends and nights
and then drive on sunday mornings
because you're broke
right
and danielle as part of your membership
you have access to the debt snowball
tool so start plugging in all of your
numbers and add in that extra income
and i guarantee you it's not going to be
five years for you to pay off this debt
looking at these numbers and what your
new take-home pay is going to be even if
you stayed in this career my guess is it
takes two years
okay and that's i mean that's
conservative i think you can do better
than that so make it a personal
competition with yourself to see how
much more maybe you need to recheck all
of your insurance coverage and say am i
overpaying go check with xander
maybe go make sure you're not getting a
tax refund we need to change our
withholding to put more money back in
our budget every single month so start
doing those things make sure you've
paused investing so that you're not
having a money leak over there while
you're trying to pay off debt go do a
budget audit get super nerdy which you
know you know how to do that really well
and i think you're going to feel the
progress when you go where else can i
start shaving some money i'm not going
to eat out i'm going to go to aldi
instead of publix just get creative with
it and see what kind of traction you
make and i it kind of gets addictive
john can i give you a a secret uh like a
life hack
yes bring it on confidence is not
something you think yourself into
confidence is something you
you achieve your way into i'm going to
practice these things so i want you to
do a 30-day sprint where you're going to
work like crazy and save as much as you
can don't go out to eat don't go do
crazy things don't rent a movie just do
30 days and send that check and see how
that feels and that should give you a
hit of confidence and confidence and
it's going to grow over time the more
you stay invested in this game
beautifully set that puts this hour of
the ramsay show in the books my thanks
to john deloney all the folks in the
booth and you america we'll be back with
you before you know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by dr john deloney and we are excited
even pumped to take your call that's
right
eight two five five two two five we'll
talk about your life your money your
mental health your relationships your
boundaries or lack thereof we're here
for you america and hannah joins us in
williamsburg pennsylvania hannah welcome
to the show
hi hey how you doing i'm good are you
guys done fantastic what's your question
today
my question is um my husband and i are
currently in a rent to own situation um
with my parents
a property that my parents currently own
um
my husband just recently i guess he's
been listening to different financial
advisors and
i guess some of them advise not to do
that um to go to the bank and get a loan
out and like pay it out and then just
have a loan through the bank and i was
um we just been talking about it
recently and i was wondering what um
your guys's advice would be
what's the agreement with the family as
far as purchasing this home
um as in
you said you said rent to own so what
are the terms of that are you guys
paying market rent and then at some
point it just becomes yours
yeah at this point it's like there's a
set price that we've agreed to
and
um
we just kind of like keep our own book
work as to when we have got that paid
off and then when it's paid off it's
ours in that sense and then we would do
then we would go to the bank and do the
paperwork to switch it over
oh so is it a certain point you go get
the loan and it becomes yours
no you're not talking about bank you're
talking about going to title company and
having it yeah yeah sorry oh okay okay
he's kept talking about getting a loan
but i'm confused
i guess he was thinking some people were
some financial advisors were saying it's
not smart to do like an agreement just
with among family to like go and get a
loan from the bank and say pay our
parents out for it
and then just owe the bank money and
slowly pay off
yeah it does get messy when it's family
and you're kind of paying into something
you know you've never had an issue and
my parents have done this with my other
siblings like my parents own a couple of
rental properties and they've done this
with them
so i mean i've see i've seen it work out
you know so i don't know that's what i
thought well
how long are you how long are you in
debt to your parents
um so we've been here about two years i
think we have about
just over eight more years
if we just do the bare minimum payments
right now um
to finish paying it off and are they
doing are they charging you no interest
yeah no interest
okay
so what does that amount to the amount
you will have paid over that time
um
currently i think about right now we
have about just over 60 000 left
okay i'm just wondering are you paying
more into it than the home is actually
worth
no or is this an incredible deal for you
guys because
no interest yeah did you pay in 100
grand and the home's worth 300.
they're they're charging us like they
bought it and they remodeled like they
they did some upgrades and stuff so they
pretty much just charged us
what
innocence i guess was they paid for it
just plus the
upgrades that they did nothing but that
that doesn't like i could care less
about that if the if they bought the
house for 500 000 they put 200 000 in it
and then they they're 700 000 in it but
the house is worth 350
they're ripping you off right so
no no no no it's not um
it's not um i don't
i'm i'm trying to even think what the
original set price was that's okay we
trust you like you you're getting a
great deal on it and it's an interesting
you're asking should we should we go get
a loan today to be done with the parents
side and just give them the 60 grand and
say hey we're good
yeah i guess a lot of people have just
been in his ear saying no that makes me
feel better because then it's actually
mine my home's on you know my name is on
the title and if something happens it's
my house and i wasn't paying into this
for eight more years all for something
to fall through
yeah i think that's where i think he's
more caught up yes so
i would guess that he's got more of a
problem with
um
well i'll just ask you a hard question
we'll just we'll just do this here
do your parents speak into how you raise
kids what you're doing does is there
does he comment on your husband's work
like oh i wouldn't be driving a ford i'd
be dr right is there a participation in
his life in that way
no
okay actually not i feel like my parents
are very much the opposite okay i mean
he would tell you i feel like that's his
thing like he when we talk about it he's
always like i never feel like he would
be like that and i never feel but he's
always like i see this happen with other
people right
and
i think that's more of our hiccup like
we've seen it or hear things that you
know they've somebody else has done a
rent to own and then you know something
happened in the parental
child relationship that it bit on that's
right or you're gonna have a kid and
then it's like oh no my kid is not going
to that school and it's like well that
is the school now we've got a whole mess
and it's like i'm thinking about i mean
we just had our first job within the
last two months i mean we still haven't
seen any like hiccups but i'm sure so
here's what i mean george saying they're
not going to guarantee that there's
hiccups your parents may be amazing they
may be wonderful
our show wouldn't exist if people
weren't following plans that everybody
else told them to do and they went
sideways yeah you see what i'm saying
and so uh
like i'll let george tell you the math
of it i think this is a there's no way
to go forward without a hard
conversation
okay this would have been a way easier
conversation on the front end saying hey
we'd love to buy this house but we want
to go
we want it to be ours and so we'd love
to buy it at the price you're offering
but we want to go to a bank and do it
now y'all are a couple years into it and
you're kind of into it right
okay do you love the house do you want
to live there
yes you know and this is like and it's a
it's a house that's been in my family
um like my grandfather built it so it's
kind of like we wanted to keep it in the
family it's kind of why we did it
okay
well if i'm in your shoes i would go get
get write them a check and go get a loan
and pay this thing on our own and have
our name on the title
okay
and then how much are you guys in debt
at all other than the mortgage
um yeah we have a we have a car loan
okay
well our a1 is getting rid of the car
loan yeah that's so that's what we've
been working on right now okay how much
how much do i make a year
um so that's a little bit different
because i just stopped working when we
had our son i'm going to guess
he's the only one working i'm thinking
and he just got a raise so don't quote
me but i'm thinking we're going to be
just over between 60 to 70 this year
okay and you think it's gonna take you
eight years to pay off sixty thousand
dollars that's what it was that okay
okay what is your renter minimum payment
um what's the rent amount every month
uh 600. oh okay so this is this is real
low rent you're paying that which is why
it's taking so long to get it to 16.
that's why we were knocking out other
debt we got our credit card debt away
and we were we're working on our car and
then it was going to be like okay then
we were going to knock out the house but
if we just did bare minimum yeah this is
a snail's pace if you go get a loan for
60 grand from your local credit union
and you go hard at that thing and you
start paying a thousand fifteen hundred
bucks a month two thousand dollars a
month this thing is going to be gone
within a few years instead of eight
and that and george
you can push back and say you're an
idiot deloney um i would never do that
we do that off air quite a bit um
if you could
come up with a mathematical way that in
two years is going to be done and go
tell your mom and dad hey in two years
we're gonna accelerate this i'm gonna go
back to work we need some open child
care because we don't want to be in
hawke's tl anymore
it is a it's a and your parents are
doing great everybody's in good doing
well together and it's interest-free i
wouldn't have a problem with it but
beyond 18-24 months go get a loan and
just simplify it yeah it's a little too
squishy for me because at any point they
can go nope still aren't technically
yeah that just makes me i wouldn't sleep
well at night
thanks for the call appreciate it this
is the ramsay show
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
guys with the rising cost of everything
these days a lot of folks are worried
about having enough money in their bank
accounts to get through the month the
good news is no matter where you're at
with money today and no matter the state
of the economy you can get on a path to
building wealth so at our building
wealth live events we've been doing
you'll learn simple common sense
principles to build real lasting wealth
and this tour is blowing up we've
already sold out two nights and the rest
of these events are on track to sell out
real soon so if you're thinking about
joining us don't wait to the last minute
because your chance might be gone
so we're going to phoenix september 12th
that's a new date because we sold out
the following night the 13th so if you
want to join us in phoenix september
12th is the date sacramento on november
1st sold out minneapolis still open
november 10th san antonio on november
15th and passes start at just 25 bucks
or you can get a four pack starting at
60 bucks go to ramseysolutions.com
events to reserve your seats now you can
hang out with dr john delony ken coleman
rachel cruz dave ramsey and i'll be
there too and so we'd love to meet you
it's been so fun going on the road john
and getting some face time with these
people and hearing their stories
and there's some electric energy in that
room yeah and you and ken do a little
pre-show if you will with some awesome
content about mental health work
relationships and how it all ties in to
building wealth yeah it's a blast you
don't want to miss it ramsay
solutions.com
events
jay joins us up next in atlanta jay
welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for having me absolutely
i'm wearing the option of
potentially going back to school for my
mba and just wanted to get
your insights and thoughts i'm a little
bit um kind of senior in my career i
have
a good income and
me and my wife are on four five and six
and
just want to see what y'all's thoughts
are and things that i should be
considering so why an mba
so currently i'm i'm in
the accounting field and i work with a
working large
public
company i'm wanting to more transition
to like an fp net or financial planning
analysis or strategic role
there to say
do you have a role in mind that is mba
required like i've got a i got a friend
who's an exec with a comp with a large
company
and they asked him to join the
senior tier
but it's nba is a minimum and so he's
having to go back and get an mba so that
he can join like it's just that's i
don't care how much experience you have
this is just a credential to get into
the door
and i'm inviting you is it one of those
kind of things or do you think this is
going to differentiate you and you just
want this credential in your back pocket
i think it's going to differentiate me
i just started a new role at a new
company and
um was kind of exploring some career
opportunities within it and kind of
found
in talking to some folks that you know
transitioning from accounting to some of
the other roles is a little bit more
difficult so thinking that i might have
this degree might help me make that jump
a little bit easier i'm just wondering
if there's other you know financial
planning certifications that you could
do that are faster cheaper that don't
require an mba because in my experience
like john mentioned some there's some
requirements but a lot of the times
people kind of feel stuck and they just
go well i'm going to go back and get my
mba and hope things work out and so i
don't want you going down that path to
where this is a waste of time doesn't
increase your income doesn't get you to
where you want to be
so i would just do some more research
and have conversations with those
employers or check their requirements
and a lot of times sometimes the mba
isn't nice to have but increasingly i
think they're less important unless
you're in one of those fields like john
mentioned the the here's the the last
data i looked at jay and i've been out
of university setting for um a couple
years now okay the last data i looked is
if you can afford it if you pay cash for
it
and you can go to a excellent school
and you are committed to getting inve
involved with your class
okay like you make
close deep connections with your
classmates and your professors that it's
an extraordinary buy
okay
if you are simply see if you are trying
to learn how to do some things and this
is an avenue that you want to take in an
adjunct to the work that you're doing
every day and you can afford it um it's
a good investment if you're going to go
take 250 000 in loans out and mortgage a
job that you don't even have yet it's
insanity
if you're gonna just do the bare minimum
to get the credentials so you can
move on with your life it's insanity
okay
okay
so don't go don't go borrow a bunch of
money is that is that ultimately what
you're asking us
yeah it was going to be cash free or you
know we were going to do it um we were
going to cash flow it um you know we
don't have any debt other than our
mortgage and
uh make a
pretty good income to tr um to kind of
cash flow and getting it i would sit
down with some of your senior leaders
and just say hey what does this jump
look like just get some clarity there
but if you're in cash flow man i don't
have a problem with it just make sure
you all know what you're investing in
and make sure you go if you're going to
do it go all in
okay as our friend ken coleman would say
make sure that your education matches
the goal and so that's what i'm trying
to confirm here that's the right path
for him instead of just you said
something important george people often
just get stuck in their career and they
think well i'm just going to go get a
graduate degree and maybe that will be
the
and often it's not often you find
yourself highly indebted or you've just
spent three or four years like when i
was in education and i knew i want to
learn more about mental health getting a
phd in counseling was an avenue towards
becoming
very skilled at a particular thing very
specific purpose right right
all right kevin joins us up next in
miami kevin welcome to the show welcome
to miami
i apologize for that yes
hello thank you so much for having me
sure i've been a big fan of you guys for
a while now
um so my question it's more
of an advice is on what
i should or we should have done with my
fiance
on saving for our wedding and setting up
after we moved in
okay what's the issue currently
so well right now we're both going to
school uh i'm working we're both working
full time
so as you might know miami's pretty
expensive area to live in oh yeah so
yeah so we're going to school and and
working it's
we can't really do double shifts kind of
since we're doing full time hopefully by
next year we will be graduating from um
college so that should help a lot
but at the moment i'm not sure
right well right now i'm doing fifteen
percent of my income
towards the savings or church retirement
fifty percent or
are you guys out of debt yeah both of
you uh
well i am
out of debt um i finished paying off
about
19 grand which was my car maybe six
months ago awesome following the baby
steps
and so
right now well once we move in or we get
married the debt will really have will
be her car
if we even keep it because right now
we're talking
we we have decided or she has decided to
sell the car
um to sell the car to get rid of the
debt and get a
maybe a leader car you know unless yeah
that's a good so you're you're trying to
make sure you cash flow this wedding and
so you're wondering how does this all
play into it
yeah when is the wedding and
uh we're
hoping to well the wedding day is april
28th okay yeah so we've got some time
you know how much it's going to cost
uh well we're doing everything ourselves
we're doing very budget very
humble i guess it's costing about
13 grand total
and is that on you two to pay for all of
that no family help
uh well
they have helped us with about six grand
together both of them and you still owe
13 on your end
uh no no it'll be the difference okay so
that i'm just trying to get on paper
what is the goal the goal right now is
seven thousand dollars by april
to make sure we pay all the vendors and
deposits and all that good stuff and so
then the question becomes can i save up
seven thousand dollars while doing all
this other stuff while going to school
while working full-time while investing
and if the answer is no then it's okay
to pause right now and stack up cash so
that we don't go into debt for this
wedding
yeah correct but i feel like you're dude
you've been going hard you paid off that
car 19 grand you could save up seven
thousand dollars between now and april
and probably still invest 15 right
uh yeah i i think so and we also say
with confidence kevin yes
no confidence okay that didn't instill a
lot but i'll take it kevin i will take
it i believe in you man you call us back
if you need help and once you guys are
married combine bank accounts and then
start attacking her debt after the
wedding day there you go thanks so much
for the call this is the ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast joined by
dr john delaney host of the dr john
dolone show which has been just
exploding in popularity john so
congratulations on that pretty well you
can catch it on youtube podcast you name
it and all of those shows that i just
mentioned are on the ramsey network and
you can find them on youtube or wherever
you listen to podcasts and i encourage
you to do so open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five tyler joins us up next in anchorage
alaska tyler welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me
yeah what's going on
yeah so um just wanted to call in i'll
be moving i'll be relocating with my
company here in the next couple weeks i
was intending on buying a house that
fell through
so the equity in my house is just going
to be sitting in
in the bank account um and
i've got a rental set up and i'm trying
to make the decision of you know
pursuing a home purchase still for
myself and my family or um you know
taking the dive and paying off my only
outstanding debt uh which is my student
loans uh still
so just kind of wanted to get some
advice from you guys on that
how much should you have in student
loans
uh i've got forty seven thousand dollars
still outstanding okay and what's your
income
um i got uh it's about 150 a year um
that's gross about 8 000 take home each
month fantastic
and
you're talking about your family here
and moving where are you moving to from
alaska
uh we're moving to the midwest um we're
going to ohio okay what's the net
profits of the home sale going to be
um so it's going to be around 100 and
uh
120 130 something like that okay how
much money do you guys have in the bank
outside of that
um we've got
somewhere around 20 to 25 000
um in savings so and then uh you know
bit of personal information but um
possibly heading into a divorce um
heading down there too so so certainly a
hard time yeah thank you for that
certainly a hard time um you know i
don't want to get on my feet and make
sure i do all the right things and i
think you know it'd certainly be nice to
have one less you know uh thing over my
head and get rid of all the debts and
and finally be debt free as i've had
this for about five years now paying off
slowly so well regardless of an
impending divorce i would tell you to
get rid of all your debt before going
into another home purchase that's going
to make it a lot less stressful so with
that 120 130 you get from the home sale
we are going to clean up that student
loan debt which is still going to leave
you with what 70 grand or so
yup something like that which will
become your new kind of down payment
savings i would leave the 2025 there as
your emergency fund and you could be
going into a storm and so i think it's
really wise to rent for a while until
you know what's next for you go rent for
a year and then save up on top of that
you've got a big pile of cash once you
know what's next for you you can buy a
house in the future
tyler did your does your
spouse have an equity claim to this
it's a part of this money yeah it
it it would be it would be split um
almost entirely i think with our savings
and the home equity we'd each kind of
walk away with eighty to ninety thousand
dollars uh once everything's settled so
okay okay
um
tyler you can listen to this i'm asking
george this question um this is gonna go
counter to what i've said over and over
and over again so tell me punch holes in
this if i'm if i'm wrong
the
and again i say this tongue-in-cheek but
the latest word is there's going to be
some sort of announcement on what the
final plan with the student loan
forgiveness will be coming in the next
couple of weeks
i would if this was me
i would wait two weeks before i did just
find out what the what what they say is
going to happen i have an idea of what's
going to happen and it's not going to be
to wipe out all 47 thousand dollars of
this dude's loans but of tyler's loans
but
is that worth waiting for that or is it
i'm not i'm just not giving that
credence anymore
i mean i wouldn't give it credence but
there's not going to be a lot of harm in
waiting two weeks either okay my guess
is they just kick the can down the road
they say we're going to forgive this
very specific portion of people who got
scammed or this level of de it's not
going to make a huge dent
but if you want to wait two weeks and
then pay him off either way regardless
of the divorce i'm going to pay these
off as part of this move and part of the
home sale to clean up my mess and have a
solid financial foundation because
you're going to need that regardless of
what happens next with this move in the
divorce but yeah i mean if you want to
wait two weeks i'd he would it would
blow my mind if they were like no matter
how much debt you have it's it's wiped
away america we're clearing the decks
right it's only happened once and it was
jesus who did it and uh the white house
ain't wiping nothing away so uh sure
we're wishing you the best tyler with
what's next man that's absolutely
there's a lot of life change that's
about to happen but the good news is uh
you are going to clean up this debt real
fast you've got a great income and uh
we're wishing you the best with this
move and this new career thing and this
this divorce situation that's tough
isaiah joins us up next in oklahoma city
isaiah welcome to the show
hey guys how can john and i help
so i had a question about purchasing a
semi truck
okay is this it for your business
right i'm currently a local
no george he's gonna drive it around the
neighborhood john stranger things have
happened
i'd probably make more money but anyway
so
it's essentially like buying a house
almost i mean they cost
upwards of two hundred thousand dollars
um
the only thing it's i guess it's like a
20 down payment as well
but the long term is more like a car
five six seven eight years
and
i just wanted you guys advice if that
would be a wise decision right now at my
age or not what are you doing now for
work
um i'm a local cdl driver truck driver
okay how old are you
26. do you have any debt currently
yes i've got
about 5 000 student loans
15 on a car
and about 140 on my mortgage
okay
well uh you're not going to like my
answer but it is not to buy a 200 000
semi-truck
and go into debt for that
but hey
like you just met us and you didn't
really meet us from the phone
please whatever you do don't take out a
200 000 mortgage
against a depreciating asset please okay
and this is this is the future you
talking to yourself through me and
george don't do this don't do this don't
do this it's gonna be really hard to get
a business off the ground when you have
you know four hundred thousand dollars
in debt looming on your shoulders as you
try to kick-start a brand new business
at 26.
so what's wrong with your current job it
sounds like you're not happy there
no i mean it's
i mean it's got it's ups and downs the
pace
not bad i mean i'm home every night um
i just
you know it's the if you bought your own
truck is
you could possibly be just successful
and just make
just money on end i guess you just you
just said it you just said it perfectly
possibly
yeah and the other side possibly is you
can have four hundred thousand dollars
in debt as a 26 year old
and
um you think you know what stress is
you have four hundred thousand dollars
worth of banks sitting on top of you man
and it will take your soul
right and
that's why i just wanted to hear from
you guys because i didn't know if
that is a lot i mean almost half a
million i guess but
if that would be any kind of exception
just because you could make
okay uh
we i wouldn't take out 200 000 loan to
to buy a burger stand i wouldn't take a
200 000 loan to buy a lawn business like
i'm not going to take out a loan to buy
a business
because i
i don't know when the next cove is
sitting around the corner man i don't
know when the next government regulation
on a thing is gonna
come into i don't know when they're
gonna gas is gonna go up to 17 an hour
and i've got my own i mean 17 dollars a
mile or whatever
that's not really any calculation for
gas but you know what i mean i don't
know any of those things but the bank
still gets their money every month and
i'm just not going to live like that we
we run our business here at ramsey
solutions completely debt-free at the
speed of cash
and that's what you need to be doing as
well if you want to be successful as an
entrepreneur and so that means we're
gonna clean up our personal mess here
we're gonna get rid of the student loan
the car loan uh you could make the
mortgage will fall into baby step six
but if you wanna do this it means it
might be seven years from now when we
save up a hundred grand and we buy a
used semi in cash to kick-start this
business hey i think it's a good
call-out george most people don't know
dave built half this building
he just built half one wing it was just
like a one-winged airplane but we'll do
the rest we have the gas when we have
cash we'll do the rest and then we've
got the cash do the rest but it's
literally at the speed of cash
right and you can do it i'm going to
send you a copy of dave's book entree
leadership it's wisdom from the trenches
in business and part of that talks about
how to do this uh with financial peace
as you kickstart a business so hang on
the line austin will send you a copy of
entre leadership thanks for the call
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up america you're listening to
the ramsay show i'm george campbell
joined by dr john dolone our question of
the day comes from blinds.com their 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color as
john and i are prone to do they will
remake your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best deal
all right the question comes from kate
in kentucky kate writes i'm 23 years old
i started working in banking at 16 and
never went to college because i didn't
enjoy school and wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom
i'm not married and i have no kids after
working through my mental health
challenges over the past 18 months i
realized i have a lot of work potential
and i think it would be a good idea for
me to go to college
my job will pay a hundred percent for
a's
90 for b's and eighty percent for c's up
to three thousand bucks a year i've
never seen that fascinating that's like
a it's like a it's how grandparents do
it yeah that's awesome some incentive up
front i would need to purchase a laptop
then pay for the books and anything
above the three thousand dollars along
the way
i'm currently in baby step four and
wonder if i should stop retirement
contributions altogether just go down to
the match or get a second job to cash
flow college
so there's a lot of
unknown variables in here like how much
do you make a year you have a stable
place to live all that kind of stuff um
but we do know she's out of debt and
she's investing has an emergency fund if
she's saying she's on baby step four
there you go but i do like this i do
like um i didn't want to go i didn't
want to go to school right away so i
went to the workforce and now i've got a
couple years in and now i find a thing
that i think i like and now i'm ready to
double down on it which i love that's
great self-awareness at 23. most people
realize that at 43 exactly and they have
a lot of regret and feel like they
wasted a lot of time that's right but um
my recommendation would be to go
begin at a community college three
thousand bucks can get you a long way um
at a community college and begin to get
a lot of this work underneath you
and then begin to figure out what comes
next after that yeah my personal goal
would for her i like her second option
of getting a second job to cash flow
college and going to a school that's as
affordable as possible right because it
sounds like she's not quite sure
what the path is and community college
is a great place to not you're not
wasting time you're getting all your
prerequisites in you can always transfer
to a different school and finish out a
four-year degree if you want to do that
but i love the idea of her continuing to
invest i mean she's been working since
16 who knows how long she's been
investing yeah and how that's going to
set her up for success to be a baby
steps millionaire very early in life so
is it okay to stop the job retirement
contributions while you're doing this
um it would be if it means the option is
to go into debt okay for your student
loan i would say okay we're gonna do
anything we can to pause right now and
this is kind of a storm we need to make
sure we cash flow education and if that
means going down to the match for a
temporary period of time i would be okay
with it but i love the idea of the
second job
uh to cash flow it now it's gonna be a
lot going to college and working two
jobs we may have to scale that back down
but if the job covers 3000 and that
covers community college that solves a
whole lot of problems so we can focus on
the job in school so thanks for the
question kate appreciate that christine
joins us up next in minneapolis
christine welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can john and i help
um i'm calling i have a question for you
um i recently inherited some money and i
would like to use um some of it maybe
about half of it to
buy a house and pay cash i have a
financial advisor that is telling me to
just put 20 percent down
on the house and then invest the rest
with him
i could have yes that was going to be
the response christine that's bananas
do you trust your financial advisor
well
it's a new financial advisor i've never
really worked with one before but with
this inheritance i thought i better
get the advice okay how much is the
inheritance
um just under a million wow and where
did it come from um the death of my
father ah i'm sorry how recent was this
uh last fall
what was his name
david good guy
yeah
that's pretty amazing he left quite the
legacy
yeah
how old are you
i'm 53 53 incredible so what's your
financial situation right now do you
have any debt do you have money in the
bank
i have a 401k
no debt and i have a pretty decent job
okay and you have an emergency fund
already
um no but i thought i would build it up
with that money that was that's quite
the emergency fund
so do you have a home currently
well i'm recently divorced so i have to
go out and buy my own place now on my
own okay are all the eyes dotted and t's
crossed on the divorce
yes okay
so can we pause before you answer george
yes christine
yes
i want
i'm smiling here because you know i
you're really smart
and you're coming
out of one tragedy followed by another
tragedy
and somewhere along the way probably a
lot of different times
you've been convinced that you're not
smart or that you shouldn't trust
yourself you should trust other people
and you know like you're just telling me
and george you know exactly what you
should do
and yet you ran into a financial advisor
that was giving you bananas bonkers
information
so george is going to walk you through
this but i want you
from this moment forward to never again
believe that you're not smart is that
fair
sure thank you
is it am i right
yeah
yes you are really smart and you've done
a good job and your dad did a great job
with you
you're lucky and he was lucky both of
you fear
thank you yeah awesome beautifully said
john
so as far as your situation christine i
think it's very wise to buy a reasonable
house in cash you can invest the rest of
that money
and i would fire a financial advisor
today and say hey thanks so much for all
the advice i'm going to be moving on do
it and song christine just sing that
would be nice but i would connect with
one of our smartvestor pros at
ramseysolutions.com they've got the
heart of a teacher and uh they'll
actually help educate you on why they're
saying what they're saying and they're
not gonna just say oh christine you
shouldn't you should put 20 no you
shouldn't buy a house in cash they're
going to say fist bump that's awesome
you bought a house in cash how can we
help you make the most and maximize all
of this wealth that you've amassed and
that's what i want for you from a
financial advisor that's what you're
looking for as you start interviewing
them
so that's what i encourage you to do
what what does a reasonable house look
like for you
well
um you know two years ago i was looking
at
um anything kind of in the 300s but
now
with the way the home prices have
inflated um
those comparable homes are now in the
force and close to five so
okay are you gonna stay in the in the
area that you're in
yes
okay
um
one of my mentors told who taught me
about counseling and about especially
dealing with life after trauma
one of his rules was six to nine months
six months to a year after something
hard like the loss of a loved one after
a divorce
don't make any wild major decisions but
if you're staying in the same area
you've been in a long time you know this
area right this isn't a wild decision
for you this is where your life is is
that right
yeah that's absolutely true okay okay
and when it comes to a large sum of
money sometimes it helps to have some
balance because you may feel out of
balance going and buying a house right
now and so i like to look at it through
the lens of give safe spend so may we
give some to a charity you're passionate
about your local church wherever you
want to give
bless someone with that we're going to
save some we're going to invest a chunk
of this and we're going to spend it
spend it on christine what would
christine want to do would christine
want to go on a trip does she need to
upgrade the car does she need a mani
pedi i don't know what that is for you
but enjoy it too i think your dad would
have wanted that would you agree
yep i as the dad of a six-year-old
little girl
i can think of nothing else
then i'm able to leave her close to a
million dollars one day
when i pass away and she's coming off a
situation where she's not safe and she's
exposed
and i've set her up in a position to go
buy herself a home with cash
i can't think of a cooler thing that i
could as a dad i can leave my daughter
other than character and love and all
that stuff
do you think your dad would would be
honored by you going to buy yourself a
home
oh yes he'd love that yeah that's great
how much do you have in your 401k
christine
uh about
close to seven hundred thousand that's
incredible well you can go ahead and max
out your 401k for the year while you're
at it just drive yourself i mean you're
doing so great so proud of you thank you
so much for trusting us with this call
we appreciate it that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books my thanks
to dr john deloney all the guys and gals
in the booth austin and will and andrew
and kelly and you america we appreciate
you listening we'll be back real soon
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
uh
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast joined
today by dr john doloni best-selling
author and all-around good guy and we
are excited to take your call today
825-5225 let's talk life money
relationships boundaries mental health
let's do it you had thoughts about that
add that to your resume all around good
guy
it is that's the on the top of my resume
it's got my name and underneath it in
comic sans it just says all around good
guy way below is two phds blah blah blah
that matters yeah okay love it and on
george's resume says george campbell and
underneath it says where's denim and
corduroy in august and self-proclaimed
renaissance man that's on there too no
thanks tom hanks well let's go to the
phones that's where that's what the
show's all about marcy joins us up next
in jackson mississippi marcy welcome to
the show
hey guys it's so cool to get to talk to
y'all we are honored to talk to you how
can we help today
i've got a weird question i'm gonna give
you a little bit of background otherwise
it's gonna sound kind of crazy
marcy this is what we do for a living
just bring it
all right well my husband was delivered
from 20 years of drug addiction and has
been clean for three years wow um yes
god's restored our broken family but our
finances are still pretty broken
um during his act of addiction he would
take unnecessary er visits he would take
out payday loans
um it's just
just messed us up so now we're ready to
clean up the mess together
um we don't know what he owes because no
one's actively collecting and he had
hidden the bills and destroyed a lot so
i have no idea i have an idea
and the number scares me because when i
checked a few years ago it was
i mean we're heading up toward two
hundred thousand dollars
um so can i ask you about what you owe
when you don't know what you owe why
didn't you all deal with it then
he was still in active addiction um he
was still hemorrhaging money out of our
family um we separated soon after that
and i went into survival mode good deal
good for you yeah
good for you where are you guys at today
as it stands financially
um i am working he
turned in very last paper for his
seminary degree today
um
he will be looking for teaching job
um i went full time well he's he wants
to do college he wants to go for his phd
but he wants to be teaching too uh he he
agrees that he needs to be contributing
to the finances
yes i could i agree too
we all agree on that yeah and um it's
going to be very difficult to find
just a college teaching job right out of
the gate so he's going to need to have
another plan and i'm coming from the
college world okay i've hired a number
of people through that system it's going
to be a tough sled sled it's give me a
tough sledding ahead so he might want to
find the high school teaching job he
wanted to find another job that he can
do in the meantime while he's sending
out resumes like school starts next week
or in two weeks across the country and
so faculty hiring is on a cycle and he's
probably looking at next year before he
would land even a part-time gig
yeah
yeah he also builds computers so he's
looking at stuff like that he's helped
um looking for jobs building web pages
and um kind of checking out adjunct
positions for january good deal that's
wise right there there you go so what is
the current debt that you know of that
you guys have as a household
as a household um i know for sure that
together we owe about 65 000 um probably
no problem 85 000 in student loans with
his stuff
and then um
mine and the kids medical is going to
run probably under a thousand
as far as what i know for sure i mean
when i added up all of his bills back in
2017
it
it was hard to figure it out because
some of the bills would come in
and they would be like adding on to a
previous bill
so i tried to weed all that out but when
i finished adding it all up plus the
student loans on his side it was around
150. i know it's higher than that now do
you still have any of those bills
i don't when we separated i packed it
all up in a box and i handed it to him
and
um i don't care what you do with it but
you know where those bills came from
right you know hey it was from this
hospital it was from this lender yeah
okay well i know which hospitals i don't
know
debt collector at some point
so i would start there of what you know
and go to all those lenders go to the
hospital and say hey i want to make sure
that we our accounts are clean can you
look up our name let us know you know
bring any documentation because you guys
have nothing and so what you need right
now is to try to find all the
documentation you can find from all of
these places to find get a real picture
of what this adds up to
because some of it may have disappeared
into the ether they may have written it
off i'd go pull a credit report on all
three credit reporting agencies too and
they're going to tell you what
outstanding debts you have what other
companies are claiming you owe them and
you can pull those for free i believe it
was once a year they may have increased
that to where you can pull at any time
with covid stuff but you can definitely
pull those for free i'll do that on both
of you to get a real picture of what is
out there as far as documentation
okay
that would be my first plan
you also have the pile of debt you know
about so either way we're attacking a
bunch of debt and we're gonna try to
stockpile as much money as we can uh
which is gonna help if he starts working
soon and i'm happy to talk to him or he
wants to call this show or call my show
or you can talk to him through or we can
talk you can talk to him via me and
george here but this is not the season
to wait for the dream job he needs to
get his butt to get to work okay he's
run the family into a significant
financial hole
and um i'm proud of the the growth he's
done i'm proud of the healing he's done
he needs to get his butt to work he
needs to start making a lot of money
right
what is your current household income
um
i i went full time this year i was i was
going with my kids but right now we're
still homeschooling but just not doing
it very well
um i'm gonna make about a hundred
thousand this year and that's okay
significant increase well that's great
news i was hoping you had a big shovel
because you got a big mess to clean up
what does child care look like
um well he's been child care so when
because i'm a nurse so i can work odd
hours so we're still going to tag team
and just be home with the kids because
we don't live close to any town okay so
it's hard to get child care can you work
any double shifts over time anything
like that
oh yeah because i think your income
right now with the way you can ramp it
up is going to be more helpful than
anything he could bring in uh for the
short term
right hey marcy can i can i poke on
something for a second
sure
you're still carrying this family right
now
yeah
that's getting real real heavy isn't it
it's been heavy for so long i just don't
even know what to do with it i mean it's
just it just is there's it is you're
right and you've done what you had to do
but when he said can i come back and you
said yes and it's going to be different
and this is what i need and he said i'm
all in
you haven't held him to that standard
is that fair
that's fair you've given him a lot of
grace to heal which is great
now it's time for him to take a
significant chunk of the burden you've
been carrying for a long long time
cool yeah yes cool okay
conflict deferred is conflict amplified
okay stop being a peacekeeper now now
that he's out of school he's gonna get
his butt into work and he's gonna get a
job he's gonna be a contributor to this
family which by the way is gonna
significantly aid in his healing down
the road
but it's time to stop talking it's time
to stop
high five and it's time to get to work
get a big mess to clean up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by my
good friend dr john deloney you're
listening to the ramsay show
right now you're hearing a lot of
talking heads in the news stirring up
fear about the real estate market and if
you believe them you think the housing
market is going to crash and it's going
to be a repeat of what we saw with the
2008 housing crisis but you're not
hearing the truth and you can't make
decisions based on fear you need the
facts and here's the facts in 2008 there
was huge supply of homes but not enough
buyer demand so home prices dropped but
that's not what's happening in today's
market right now there are half as many
homes for sale and twice as many buyers
you do the math america that means home
prices aren't going down anytime soon
they're just growing at a slower rate so
if you're ready to buy or sell your home
you don't need to wait you can still win
in this market but you've got to work
with an experienced real estate agent
we've done the hard work of vetting the
agents that know your local market and
have the transactions to back it up this
is not your brother-in-law who just got
his license these are pros who sell tons
of homes and help folks buy tons of
homes every year so if you want to
connect with one of our ramsey trusted
agents for free go to
ramseysolutions.com
agent and check out our endorsed local
providers program again that's
ramseysolutions.com
agent
let's go to the phones this hour it's a
free call triple eight eight two five
five two two five riley joins us up next
in atlanta riley welcome to the show
hey how you all doing great how can we
help
um so me and my fiance have a four-month
internship coming up
and um it's about an hour and a half
commute depending on traffic there and
back
so three hours total per day
it's about 50 to 60 hours per week
working and we were wondering if we
should try to find a
four-month lease like an apartment kind
of closer to the office
or if we should just commute
is this a paid internship
uh yes we will both be making about 20
000 each over those four months
okay over four months 20 000 each so
we're talking
uh 40k over four months
as your income and that will be your
income
what is this internship
uh it's for an accounting firm we're in
school right now to uh we're going to
the cpas
and how old are you
she's 19 and i'm 20. okay
cool and you're wondering if it's worth
it for the three hour commute to do this
internship
yes um some of the apartments in the
area are about 12 to 1500 a month and
then that's just rent that's not
including other expenses but living by
ourselves so where do you where do you
live where do you live now
we live in villarreco georgia it's about
a um like i said about an hour and a
half i mean like do you have an
apartment do you all share an apartment
together or something like that
no we uh live at my parents house still
okay
for free or are you guys paying rent
for free we have no debt 100 chance
george you can jump i'd drive i wouldn't
go rent an apartment
that's what i would do that's just me
you're in a lot a lot of uh fiance time
that's for sure
so that's good you're gonna know you're
gonna find out if this was a good
decision to put uh to put a ring on it
you're three hours in the car together i
don't think my wife could handle three
hours of me in the car we would be
listening to murder podcasts within
about 30 minutes
hey you're gonna find out now personally
i'm not a fan of commutes but if this is
the decision you made together that this
is going to be the right move for both
of your careers
it's for four months it's not forever
there's a clear defined end date to this
which makes me feel better versus we're
going to move we're not going to move
we're going to take this job three hours
away and just figure it out later but
because you're right you have free rent
right now i mean that's a that's a hard
to pass up considering it's going to be
maybe hard to find a four month lease um
anywhere in that area and you're
probably going to be paying a pretty
penny for that yeah you'd be paying a
premium for it man i i
it's going to be annoying but you're 20
years old man it's one of those things
you're going to look back and when
you're yeah
he was sleeping in vans at 19 probably
no i'm saying like i for a couple of
years i lived two and a half hours away
from where my phd program was and there
was no online classes back then so i
would get done with my job at 2pm that
day and i would drive two and a half
hours to make my class i'd go to class
until 9 pm then i'd drive home that
night to be at work the next day and i
just did that for several years yeah was
it fun no it's the worst man it was the
worst but you're gonna have some great
stories at the end of this but you just
it was just you do it right riley what's
the alternative if you guys don't do
this internship what does life look like
four months from now
if we don't do the internship that um
maybe we just continue in school still
live in my parents because i'm i'm still
working full-time right now um we're
trying to i'm trying to save every time
i can for a down payment on the house
when we finish school but i definitely
want to stay like rent free as much as
possible until we do finish college
so other other than gas are you guys
going to be able to sock away most of
this money you're making this 10 grand
per month yes
yes
that's good news i like that plan does
one of you all want to drive and one of
you not
um
my thought process was we that would be
like two thousand dollars extra we could
save per month
by taking the internship
yeah or just by commuting
um we saved two thousand dollars because
we wouldn't have to buy rent or anything
and so you're eight grand positive at
the end of the four months yeah
right right
i mean it's a sacrifice
i've done it so i've it it's just one of
those stories you're on the same page
because what worries me is she's into
this a month and she's going this is
misery and now we have to live with this
for three more months i don't think so
you just go get a three month lease i
mean it's not gonna you know i mean yeah
uh what are you guys
driving uh we're gonna take her car
because she gets she has a ford uh
escape and it gets like 25 miles per
gallon okay well luckily gas has gone
down in price lately so this is an
adventure brother y'all can sing on the
way you can uh i don't know you're going
to find out listen i have an idea stay
on the line here we're going to give you
every single deck of questions for
humans yes um
can we do that john there's like 18 of
them yeah that's true not the school
ones because they're not middle
schoolers we'll send you the ones that
make sense we're gonna send you the ones
that make sense you don't have kids yeah
i'm gonna help with the commute for the
first month or two okay y'all are just
gonna ask each other these questions
and um i thought you were gonna say you
can listen to the dr john delaney show
that way every day
having a lot of hard conversations in
that car um but hey this is you got to
promise me this after this is over if
this has strengthened your relationship
to the point that you're getting married
you got to invite us to the wedding is
that cool
oh definitely man okay cool y'all will
receive an invite all right it's very
cool like wedding crashers with uh dr
john deloney and myself can't wait
have you seen that movie yeah absolutely
probably that's not gonna happen okay
cool cool be like just me and you just
go into
actually george wouldn't go to the
wedding anyway i would hey so tell me
why why wouldn't you commute
i'm just not a fan of commutes my dad
i've never heard of anyone being a fan
of commutes but why wouldn't you commute
i live like seven minutes from work john
if i could live closer i would
i think i think part of it is i get like
car stress like the anxiety of just like
fighting like traffic and getting to
work it's a lot for me on my little body
you know
you understand
but i watched my dad i mean for the last
20 years he just retired the guy
commuted an hour each way yes in boston
in traffic and i was just going how is
he doing this yeah
that's hard man that wears these kids
exactly
such sacrifice i'm a big believer we can
all
do hard things for a short season and if
this was indefinite i'm gonna take a job
an hour and a half away it's just
commute three hour commute every day
indefinitely i'd say that's not like
it's not a good we've got uh some ramsey
team members you know one of them lives
in alabama which is not too far right on
the border of tennessee about an hour
and 15 minutes everybody still it's
quite the commute yeah but it's a
sacrifice you may go this is life right
now and we like where we live and we can
always move later and i just choose to
live as close as possible to work
and that's a decision i made for my
family john
mostly so i can go home to my dogs at
lunch that's what i was you understand i
know i i the sacrifice you make for your
dog
legendary
that's right well i appreciate the call
riley that's a
1920. now if they were like 45 and had
kids this would be a different scenario
but at 19 and 20. i don't even know if
it is i think you do hard things in
short seasons when you have a goal and
you want to get there i think um
uh
i think
we're we as a culture are trying to find
the easiest path towards every single
goal and i think one of the
things that made me appreciate my degree
made me think through it i would get out
of class and i'd have a couple hours to
think about what i just experienced in
class and did i agree with it not agree
with it
i think the entire gravity of that
process the grit and the i didn't want
to do it was hard
made the end result so much more
powerful there's a lot of growth a lot
of growth when you do hard things
especially really hard things for a
short period of time it's a gift and
we've tried we try to avoid as a culture
that's why i say man for four months
choose the hard path all right you
changed my mind john i'm with you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ramsey
personality george campbell joined by my
colleague and good friend dr john
deloney open phones this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
charles joins us up next in dallas texas
charles welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call appreciate
y'all happy to take it
what's going on uh yeah i got a kind of
unfortunate incident um
happened with my my parents uh my mother
got uh a scam call i'm sure the one
everybody's been hearing about they
called her and you know threat you know
scared her into
logging into giving her access to her
computer and all this stuff well long
story short she goes to
a couple of stores to get some gift
cards and
she she's out a couple grand
um
well i'm in i'm in the tech space and as
soon as she called me and i was kind of
on to what was happening i said i don't
know who else you're talking to hang up
phone right now
but um james has kind of already been
done at that point but um
been in touch with the uh you know ftc
and those proper
channels but you know after the fact i'm
kind of like well really can't determine
what information since they were in her
computer what information they may have
gotten
um and so i'm just kind of looking for
some type of
uh path forward just to give
my parents some peace of mind whether
it's you know a lifelock type uh product
like that just in case they did get a
get a hold of some type of information
you know so a couple years down the road
you know if it flags you know just kind
of looking for some
path forward post events um going
forwards i don't think they had any type
of identity
uh you know insurance or anything like
that up front um it's all kind of after
the fact so man i'm so sorry to hear
that that's a bummer um
is a restoration service through xander
uh identity theft protection and dave
actually he covers every single ramsey
team member with that and i actually
went through identity theft soon after i
started working here and it was a game
changer to have that in place but there
are restoration services through xander
that you can check out to help get kind
of her life back and make sure that this
there's no further damage being done uh
so i actually i covered this on a ramsey
solutions article there's like 12 things
on there obviously asking for a fraud
alert to be placed on credit
reports on those accounts and freezing
those has she done that
i believe so i think she's gotten in
touch with you know all the credit cards
unfortunately uh there's more than
there's more than one there's more than
a few but um
i believe i i don't know if she's gotten
to that point yet it was first canceled
credit cards uh a
gift card provider then to ftc
we kind of saved that not for last but
just kind of like what much they were
going to be able to do
you know i would just look in the in the
dallas area file one with your local
police they may have a way to do it
online but what happened to me i met up
with a police officer locally and that
really helped to have that official
report because you can use that when it
comes to collections and things like
that there's a legitimate uh piece of
information out there saying that this
happened
obviously you mentioned the ftc you
filed a report with them and then
obviously monitoring every single dollar
coming in and going out of her accounts
and cancelling all cards getting new
cards all of that new bank account
that's a step you could take as well
yeah they're already i already got them
on to you know doing all those things um
fortunate thing um they're very
very old school they don't even have
online banking which in this scenario
really
saves that's what i'm talking about oh
yeah
take that jinzy that's right i uh i
wrote a check the other day and i felt
right about it so good good for them
yeah exactly exactly i love it yeah well
i appreciate appreciate the advice guys
um just kind of want that you know peace
of mind going forward and i think you'll
definitely help me there yeah and i
would check out xander's id theft
protection it's a great product again we
have it on all the ramsey team members
here uh and there's a lot of things you
can do obviously they're they're not
super tech savvy so that helps but as
just rule of thumb just don't answer
calls from people you don't know and
then go and do money orders from western
union and go buy gift cards you know
have some common sense but they use a
lot of fear tactics and urgency and some
folks here at ramsey recently had to
deal with some scams and they are very
savvy now i mean they can fake they can
spoof numbers and they can spoof the
sheriff's department and the voices
sound real and so you've always got to
take a pause be very skeptical when it
comes to these calls and always they go
oh we wouldn't call you to collect no it
doesn't work like that whenever you
actually call that place that says you
owe money to so there's a lot of things
you can do for the future but this is
one of those you categorize as stupid
tax and you learn from it and you move
on
yeah uh and you know i've you know i'm
i'm actually in the i.t world and i've
preached it to her and she's so good
like the only online banking like she's
usually always so vigilant and of course
she's just kind of traumatized now but
yeah i just couldn't believe
you know
not that she fell for it was like
it can happen to anybody like they've
gotten so sophisticated
um it's really it's really scary yeah
and there's a lot of shame and guilt
that come along with that where you beat
yourself up going how was i so done
listen she's i'm sure she's a smart
woman this can happen to literally
anyone uh but she's learned her lesson
and i hope the folks listening call your
parents and tell them about this and say
hey don't answer calls from random
people don't go get gift cards if it
sounds fishy hang up and say hey i'm
going to go to the website for that
place and i'll call that number and if
they start to get angry that'd say you
know it's a scam and just hang up well
and or say hey if anyone ever calls you
for money have them call me and i'll be
happy to do that for you and i will
handle it that's right oh that's a
bummer man thanks for the call pablo
joins us up next in ontario canada pablo
welcome to the show
george john what's shaking guys we're
just south of the border living our life
man how are you doing
oh live the dream you know how it is
what's going on we're way south of the
border george is not an excellent
geography student it's just south i
never said how far south you said all
right what's up this is about
what's going on man i i got a question
gentlemen um if i got the cash pay off
my
mortgage do i pay it or do i keep
investing
what are you currently investing
um in terms of value uh percentage-wise
of your income
um
no income at the moment but uh
last two years has been very well
for me did you get laid off or did you
quit
i got laid off okay what what's your
trade what do you do
um
i was uh electrical technologist here
okay
how long have you been unemployed
a year
why
uh
some health reasons and a few other
things that
happen okay so how much is left on this
mortgage
324 and you have that in cash
i purchased the home just before colbid
as a new bill
[Music]
and it took about
six to eight months to build
so
in that meantime i was selling rental
properties
so you had some profits from those sales
that you've been just stalking away in
the bank
exactly so within
within a year or two my personal home
just tripled
and uh
so i just pocketed that cash waiting for
um
my investments to go up
luckily i cashed out at a good time
so how much money do you have in liquid
cash
well over a million wow
yeah dude pay off fast today off your
house yes what do you mean by keep
investing
well
do i do i just keep all my rrsps are
maxed out all my tfsas are maxed out
i'm just wondering it sounds like you
can do both with this level of cash
you're going to continue to invest this
home payoff is not going to hold you
back that much
yeah that's kind of my problem is do i
pay off the mortgage invest the rest and
it sounds like you just love investing
and seeing money grow and so to put it
on the house you feel like well that
doesn't make sense i could see this
money grow at 10
exactly that's my issue okay so so
here's the deal you made a killing
off one off the other side of the market
didn't you
there's a comes a moment when you keep
not dealing with the risk side of that
teeter-totter that you become
the person who somebody else makes a
whole bunch of money off of so what that
means is get rid of all of your risk
you're gonna sleep so good take your no
more mortgage off the table man like
that what are you doing man that's your
sleeping that's a it's a it's a sleep
tax man pay it dude sleep
that's not even a big part of your world
dude you got this pablo you know what to
do and i'm telling you there's nothing
like having a paid for house and you've
got plenty of other money to invest
you're gonna be multi-millionaire sounds
like you already are you're doing great
good problem to have thanks for the call
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day acts 20 35 in
everything i showed you that by working
hard in this way you must help the weak
and remember the words of the lord jesus
that he himself said it is more blessed
to give than to receive
jackie chan said i do small things i try
to do good things every day if everyone
does some good think of what a good
world this will be i love jackie chan
big fan
how can you not
all right let's go to zenya in south
carolina
zenya welcome to the show
hi y'all thanks for having me happy to
have you how can we help today all right
um well i'm graduating at the end of the
year on my 19th birthday with an
associate's degree debt free wow
and i'm getting married
in may so i was wanting to get some
advice on purchasing a car
in between
now and then
do you have a car now
i don't i've never owned a car and how
what's the urgency are you needing it to
get around right now get to work
um no not necessarily um my parents have
two vehicles so that's working out right
now and i work close by um so you're
borrowing their car
i am um i
i will be moving uh across the state
when i get to get married so in may so
are you saying you can borrow this car
until may
probably okay how much debt do you have
if any
she said none at all definitely agree
the degree is debt-free i didn't know if
there's any other debt in the picture
that's great you have any cash
um around six thousand dollars i have an
emergency fund too oh great how much is
in the emergency fund
500. um i took the
teen course so that i was gonna say it
was like 500 sounds awfully like what we
teach in our personal finance curriculum
that is awesome you've been following
this plan
yeah so if you want to buy a car right
if you want to buy a car right now
i think the the best path forward is to
go buy a local emergency room and have
them remove one of your kidneys
and get on craigslist and sell it and
that's gonna
you should be able to wrangle up enough
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars of cash to buy a good use
someone out there is going to take
john's advice don't don't dude
okay so you've got six thousand dollars
ready to put towards this car
and are you working currently
i am um
about 20 hours a week
good for you what do you
um make dollars an hour
okay
so what's your question question
because you're saying what's the what's
the best way
when should you buy it how much did you
spend
um where should i start well i think we
got to start with the goal of
doing some research and looking around
saying okay well if i bought a car today
with cash with my 6000 what kind of car
could i buy
and you can start
doing that research there's a lot of car
you know buying sites you can start with
one like auto trader and start to sort
it from low to high and go all right not
going to go with the 2 000 beater car i
could go with a 5 000
honda or toyota right and then you have
a goal in mind if you're going okay i
really want that 7 000 card and i can do
that by february if i save up another
200 a month 400 a month and so once you
set that goal it'll become pretty clear
of kind of what you're aiming for
and i would avoid you know major
dealerships to find a car in that range
you know you can look at facebook
marketplace you can look at craigslist
you can look at autotrader like i
mentioned
and from there you always want to do a
pre-purchase inspection so you that's
where you're going to take it to a
separate mechanic to get it
independently inspected before you ever
make this purchase promise me you'll do
that
i promise it'll cost probably 100 bucks
right john or 200 bucks yeah 100 bucks
200 bucks and it is worth the peace of
mind so you don't go i got a great deal
and now it needs a new transmission and
a clutch pack piston and i don't even
know what that means
um can i
xenia i'm gonna make an admission here
okay so this is my confession i am
terrible at buying cars
okay so one of the rules i have for
myself is when i'm about to buy a car i
take somebody with me who knows what
they're doing and i know about cars i
like cars um i've bought a lot of cars
in my life but i'm just terrible at
doing it i either get attached to
something i get bored with the process
and i just want to hurry it up and i
ended up buying a car that wasn't
probably the best car for me so here's
why i tell you that
are you and your dad still close
would it be possible for
your dad who's just trying to love his
daughter and be involved and she's about
to get married and graduate and move on
if you said hey dad could we go test
drive a few cars and you could teach me
what what to look for
absolutely that was actually a former
mechanic
oh gosh you would make his number one
don't call a couple of knuckleheads on
the radio and yeah what are you doing
here number two
man give him this one give your old man
this one he's gonna love this
i will he will love
and say this is how much we have i can't
spend any more than this he's probably
gonna dump some on top of it because
you're his baby girl and
everybody's gonna win but he's gonna go
to bed at night like that's right i i
she still likes me she still needs me
right what a great gift you can give to
that old man ashley don't listen to
outside people and pressure that say
well ashley you great you work so hard
you deserve a really nice reliable safe
car and that's why you have to get a new
car that's thirty 30 000 and put his
little don't do that you know you know
better but i just i'm telling you
there's a lot of pressure out there from
people and right now you got no one to
impress except dad and dad's going to be
proud of you paying cash for that car
and so and i'll tell you i bought a car
in 2017 and it cost me exactly six
thousand dollars got it from a former
ramsey co-worker honda civic 09 leather
seats
whole nine yards it was beautiful john
and that same car goes for about 76 000
and i got a wreck in 2019 and i didn't
even give a rip
because it already had body damage and
so at 19 years old i think every 19 year
old should drive kind of a crappy car
that's just a weird old man stance i
have i 100 agree i just don't think they
deserve jeep wranglers that are brand
new at 19. i don't know it's a deserved
thing i just yeah i think it's good to
put your time in you're going to bump it
against some things in you so uh take
your time with it and make make the
decision when it's right for you but
there's no wrong way to do it except for
going into debt and not getting an
inspection so thank you so much for the
call all right let's take a quick one
from ashley in maryland ashley we're up
against the clock let's get right to it
how can we help
oh sorry north dakota i thought that was
an m on my screen
you're way way far from there
we are we're almost to canada well it's
very cold up here wow um
so my husband's air force he's active
duty
we live on the air force base so we
don't pay rent just comes straight out
of his paycheck bah
we have we do not have to pay utilities
which is a huge perk um especially with
how cold it gets during the winter time
but we found a property that we're
interested in that's about 10 minutes
away
we can try and get it for 275
um
and it has two acres it's a nice nice
property but the i mean it needs a lot
of work so like the location is
beautiful ashley when are y'all gonna
have to move again
three and a half years don't do it
i'm so sorry i wouldn't
and i'm telling you as a guy who loves
acreage and the woods and if i had to
live on base i would feel like i would
feel so constricted and i see you and i
work with you and i just want to have a
place where there's not a bunch of
jacked up jeeps everywhere i get it and
yes
man in three and a half years
there's who knows i mean this property
may triple in value and it may be just a
mess up for the next three years gonna
fix this place up fall in love with it
have some peace and you got to move
again
yeah and that's what we're afraid of but
then i thought maybe the land would grow
you know you know having two acres close
to town maybe that would be worth more
in three years when we fell yeah it
might yeah it might it might um do you
have enough money to get into it
yeah
are you guys debt free with an emergency
fund and the down payment
yes so we are debt-free we have about
150 000 in the bank um
and
and so we we've been saving for eight
years for a house okay well then i take
that back i'm an idiot i mean if you can
be there for three or four years i mean
i don't know how much work does it need
um okay so it needs all new flooring we
want to do like i know i mean we don't
need a real fast i mean is this like 50
grand give me a ballpark of what you
think it would cost i yeah i'd say
probably 75 to 50 to make it look really
nice i wouldn't that's because then
you're going to put 75 down on the 275
because then you're going to need the
rest of the cash to do all these repairs
and if you don't you're going to be half
miserable in this house of this was my
vision but now i can't accomplish it
because i don't have the cash
oh
i would tread lightly um but again if
you know you're moving in three years
you're gonna just have settled in and
then all of a sudden have to go around
and turn this house you poured your soul
in that you love oh it's in tough places
hope it recoups yeah that's hard it's
not a dumb decision but i just don't
want you to have regrets either yes i
guess it's one of those that the dollars
work fine
but thanks for the college
i wish you the best thank your husband
for the service that puts this hour off
the ramsay show in the books thanks to
john deloney all the folks in the booth
and you america thanks for listening
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you